as las vegas starts to reopen now a way
to get out on the town
in style jc fernandez always getting
these fun assignments and what do you
have for us right now jc
oh kirsten we have a lot for you
including this is
the bentley uh and this is james jimmy
with all-star car rentals
tell me about the bentley and how much
can someone rent this for this
is probably uh the majority of us here
at all-star cars favorite vehicle
because you get all the bells and
whistles of luxury and exotic i want to
show you the back seat they say
the bentley one of the best seats is the
back seat so check this out this thing
is
oh such soft leather and right here you
pop this button right here and your own
little vanity pops up so you can check
yourself before you go out and hit the
town
all-star car rentals now i think ted was
talking about the aston martin
let's show everyone how this one starts
so let's loop around here to get the
inside of this car because this how much
does this go for
i believe this is at 6.99
now to start this you need to put the
key in and hold it
[Music]
listen to the per at that the engine i
mean these are dream cars i
i'm a car guy i love cars these are cars
that you dream of one day
driving and all-star car rentals gives
you that opportunity to rent one and
drive one and a night out on the town
maybe at a wedding or prom people rent
them for as well anything and everything
video shoots just photo shoots even for
modeling or you know whatever aesthetics
they needed for now let's go over here
uh this is a lamborghini the suv tell me
about this one right here this is the
urus
so you're still getting all your
lamborghini bells and whistles
but in an suv so you're still getting
600 horsepower you're still getting
plenty of fun driving
and it's just beautiful all around can
you go around look at the inside of this
lamborghini correct come on inside look
inside this thing
and how much is someone can write this
one for how much this is about 10.99 a
day
10.99 a day and can you can you you have
to stay in the state of nevada where can
you go with it you have to stay in the
state of nevada it's kind of a crazy
rule with everything here with rental
vehicles
um but we basically give you 100 miles a
day
some vehicles are 120 but we can always
arrange that for a minimal fee to go
further
jeep wrangler the moab edition this is
the highest end when it comes to a jeep
wrangler
it's named after the city of moab and
utah something like this can you take it
off-roading
i mean i wouldn't recommend it uh you
don't want somebody to roll it but i
have a feeling that
by the looks of it and being a moab
performance edition it's going to go
off-road sooner than later oh this is a
beautiful
jeep i love it all-star rentals you can
be driving this jeep this weekend
you can drive the rolls-royce the
bentley all of them it could be yours
all-star rentals what's the website
jimmy all-star cars las vegas lv love it
thank you so much for sending back to
you guys in the studio
kirsten christian ted which one do you
want me to bring back i'll bring it back
to you guys what do you want the suv
bentley what about you genie
there you go all right make it happen jc
we'll take any of them let's not be
picky right ted whose birthday is coming
up next yours
yours i don't know maybe mine yours okay
that's
it we're getting in the bentley